so when joe biden is not incoherently
babbling about illegal immigration he's
incoherently babbling about
the supposed pay gap now the pay gap is
one of the most overwrought ridiculous
things in american
public life the notion that women are
being paid less for the same exact work
is not backed
by statistical evidence the reality is
that the pay gap is almost entirely
a creation of differentials in work
hours in jobs chosen
it is a differential in time taken off
from the workforce women tend to take
more time out of the workforce because
they want to be home
with the kids in many cases the basic
idea that a woman works an hour a man
works an hour exact same job exact same
credentials and so the woman gets paid
less
is just silly it it actually is not true
it's been widely debunked christina
summers has done that work many many
times before
in fact in america's largest cities it's
been true for years that people who are
fresh out of college without having
taken time out of the workforce
women in the same industries tend to be
paid as highly or more than men that's
according to time magazine that goes
back a full decade
it doesn't matter we're still going to
keep promoting the quote-unquote
equity-based idea
that if women on average are paid less
than men for all of those extraneous
factors
for all of those confounds well you know
that's still not good enough
we have to equalize pay between men and
women and pretend that women are
not getting paid enough for the same
exact work as a man so biden's
administration earlier this week tried
out megan rapino who's the least
victimized victim
in american public life megan rappano is
an extraordinarily famous
gay woman who has not so far as i'm
aware
uh been victimized in any of her media
coverage she grew up extremely
privileged
she she did not grow up impoverished
she has faced from what i can see very
little in the way of actual life
obstacles to success
she is now treated as a paragon of
feminist virtue
even though the claims that she makes
are overtly false repeatedly
like this one here was megan rapido
complaining she's not paid the same as
the men yeah you're not paid the same as
the men
lady because you're in women's soccer
which makes money once every four years
whereas men's soccer makes money
pretty much all the time and the men's
world cup is a multiple like a large
multiple bigger
than the women's world cup and you guys
signed a contract if you don't like your
contract you could have not signed that
contract
but here's megan rapinoe complaining
that she does the same work as a man and
doesn't get paid the same as a man
four world cup championships and four
olympic gold medals for the united
states
and despite those wins i've been
devalued
i've been disrespected and dismissed
because i am a woman
and i've been told that i don't deserve
any more
than less because i am a woman
you see despite all the wins i'm still
paid less than men who do the same job
that i do
they don't do the same job that you do
they don't you know how i know
because megan rappano anytime you want
you can go play on the men's team
you can try you can try
after all gender is so it's a it's a
social construct we've been informed by
the left that gender
does not exist it's completely a social
construct so since gender is a social
construct any time megan rappano wants
she can go try and play with the men
that is not going to go great for megan
rapido she is not doing the same work
that a man is doing this is like saying
that a woman lifting weights like her
job is to lift weights
she's doing exactly the same job as a
man when she wins a gold medal
in a weightlifting competition well not
really considering the man is probably
listening twice lifting twice as much
weight
as the woman are you not put too fine a
point on this
but in a scrimmage the women's world cup
soccer team the gold medal winning
women's world cup soccer team
lost to the under 15 football club from
dallas
boys football club from dallas the under
15s a bunch of 14 year old
like yes it was a scrimmage but also
like you lost to a bunch of 14 year old
boys no
it's not no actually you're not doing
the same work as the men
it's all absurd okay it's just absurd
and her proclaiming she's speaking from
the podium of the damned white house
she's been on every major television
show complaining about her fate
she signed voluntarily a contract as to
her pay and the women's world cup again
is a fraction the size of the men's
world cup it's amazing but don't worry
joe biden assures us that there's not a
single thing a man can do a woman can't
do better not a single thing
men can't pee their name in the snow
better men can't open pickle jars better
men can't pick up heavy weights better
men can't throw a baseball harder on
average
no it turns out every single thing a man
can do a woman can do just as well or
better which is why he should probably
resign and let kamal harris be president
i've told my daughters granddaughters
from the time
they were old enough to understand what
i was saying
and i mean it there's not a single thing
a man can do that a woman can't do as
well or better
not a single thing not a single thing
anything really there are things that
women can do better than men
they're things men can do better than
women but frankly i'm shocked that he
still thinks the distinction exists he
can't even define what a woman is
it turns out that many men are better at
being women than women according to joe
biden
so have you been following the march
madness ncaa tournament i mean you'd
have to have been living on the moon not
to because
it really is exciting stuff and here's
the thing everybody
everybody puts a little bit of money on
march madness because it's just fun
well with march madness officially
beginning it's time for you to shoot
your shot score big
with the non-stop action with my bookie
so betting on sports i'm just taking a
little bit of money and putting on a
sporting game it can sometimes be
a lot of fun i've been doing it a little
bit and i got to tell you it kind of
gives me a kick
we hope guys got in on my bookie bracket
contest with cash prizes of 25
000 bucks 10 000 bucks and more but if
betting on the individual games is more
your style my bookie has you covered
there
as well sign up today at mybookie.ag use
promo code shapiro to secure a deposit
bonus up to a thousand bucks that's
promo code shapiro to claim your first
deposit bonus college ball nba nhl no
matter the support no matter the minute
my bookie puts the action in your hands
with in-game live betting and with
choice from thousands of lines and odds
you can turn any game day
into payday bet anything anytime
anywhere with my bookie again
turn sports into a little bit more fun
with my friends over at my bookie
all right so the white house released
this asinine asinine instagram
picture the other day said it's equal
payday did you know
white men make the whole dollar asian
women make 87 cents white women make 79
cents black women make 63 cents
american indian alaska native women make
60 cents hispanic or latino women make
55 cents okay so i have some questions i
have some some major questions first of
all
you're taking into account no confounds
right number of hours
in the workforce amount of time taken
out of the workforce what kind of job
you have and none of that is taken into
account second you notice that it starts
with a white men make the whole dollar
how about asian men
how do they do in the united states how
about like nigerian born american
immigrants
they do really really well in the united
states as it turns out so why are white
men
at the top oh because white men are
always evil that's why
when you just put white men at the top
that means everything that follows is
going to be how crappy america is
also are we to believe i mean according
to the left this this violates the
intersectional hierarchy
the only reason for this would be
discrimination of course right
intersectional concerns
your membership in various identity
groups that decides just how bad america
is to you
so according to this chart the one that
the white house just put out
in order of people who are discriminated
against
it goes like least discriminated against
asian american women
then white women apparently white women
are more discriminated against than
asian american women
kind of incredible wouldn't have
predicted that also it turns out
that black women are less discriminated
against
than hispanic or latino women because
black women make 63 cents
while hispanic or latino women make 55
cents so apparently america is super
duper racist against hispanic and latino
women but only like
a little bit less racist against black
women okay all of this is just crap
it's just crap it does not bear
statistical relation to reality
men have different jobs than women men
tend to go into stem fields women tend
not to go into stem fields that is not
due to systemic discrimination
all of the big tech companies have been
trying to recruit women into these
fields for a very long time
lauren summers the former treasury
secretary under bill clinton got himself
in hot water by pointing out that women
have different preferences in job
selection than men do
this happens to be accurate he also
pointed out that if you look at test
performance when it comes to math and
science what you tend to see
is that the averages for men and women
tend to be pretty similar
but that at the tail end of the spectrum
the curves are different
the male curve in terms of test scores
on math and science tends to show a lot
of really dumb men and a lot of really
smart
men and the average somewhere in the
middle and for women a lot of people in
the middle very few very dumb
and very few very great at science and
tech
okay that does not mean that if you just
pick a woman that she's going to be
worse off than a man it means that when
you're looking at a statistical average
of wages you have to look at factors
like this again women tend to enter the
stem fields less often than men
and actually when you look at countries
that have supposedly more
gender equality what you see is that
women enter stem fields there
even less often than in countries where
there is more gender inequality
why because if a woman has to get a
higher earning job in order to support
her family
it turns out that she will pick a stem
field because that's where the money is
but if you're in
the netherlands where women don't have
to get a stem job
in order to have a decent way of life
well then they won't become doctors
as often as they will go into other
forms of of job and occupation
university of chicago economist stephen
levitt says quote rather than
interpreting women's lower wages of
failure
perhaps it should be seen as a sign that
a higher wage simply isn't as meaningful
and incentive for women as it is for men
how dare we how dare we no every in
every
inequality of outcome means that america
is terrible and horrible and no good and
very bad which again
is why joe biden needs to immediately
resign and hand over his seat
to the incredible historic black woman
who is his vice president that will
solve all of our problems even though by
the way again
they can't even define man and woman if
you ask them what is a man and what is a
woman they literally have no definition
of these things
the easiest way to solve the gender gap
is to simply have people stop
identifying as a member of gender at all
because gender is irrelevant
boom no genders no pay gap incredible
we solved it guys it was that easy i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the ben
shapiro show if you did go ahead and hit
the subscribe button so you stay up to
date on all of our future content